you have finite and infinite games right
finite games where you have known
players agreed upon rules and an outcome
that wins the game right infinite game
you have known and unknown players no
rules and the point of the game is to
keep the game going and what happens is
that people apply finite rules to
infinite games and then they wonder why
it's not working what's an example so a
finite game would be like baseball know
the players at the end of the game you
tally up the ones where the most runs
and you win you can't hold the ball and
run it around the bases like there's
rules of play with an infinite game the
Vietnam War isn't a simple example
that's and NS which is basically the US
lost the Vietnam War because they were
applying a finite structure which is
we're going to win this war and the
Vietnamese people were playing an
infinite game structure which is we're
going to stay alive and keep fighting
and as long as someone is staying alive
and keeping fighting they will beat the
person who's trying to end something and
so the infinite frame always conquers
the finite and the thing is is that most
of the games worth playing are infinite